hey yo so how did you guys meet you and
Juan this is Marcus oh you guys are
related so you guys just it's called
nobody you don't think they both look
like the Mickey
Dominican
I see you one looks like he's a retired
baseball player Sammy Sosa right bro
don't look like Sammy sorry
I knew it I can't I said this last night
I agree with that now I don't know
before he went like like seeing please
because I just I just Googled sami's
house a week ago because I seen a white
picture of her yeah I don't look the
same bro I don't look no for real I
literally just see this is how God work
I literally just Googled that [__] the
other day because I was looking at the
white pictures I'm like damn this [__]
look crazy
Jeremy Sosa
turn around
put the camera so this don't look like
him let me see how you looking so I can
meet the face
no you're crazy
and you have that [__] glass on your
phone nobody can see it that's seven so
cool
blueberry can you see privacy screen can
you see no I said no I see it but I
don't see it no man that's you [__]
crazy I don't look like that [__] bro
let him grow a beer
you have stipulations yeah I don't look
like him all right check it no that's my
talented family yeah
he played football he played basketball
they they the ones for real not he rap
get money he managed to get money they
just changing their life around doing
all that type of [__]
Juan how many records have you put out
just one
are you gonna you're not rapping on
these are you no I had no say something
he got the songs he rapping he used to
rap you told me you were wrong
yeah put a beat on he'll turn up he got
no no his first take always legendary
give us a beat real quick
dumbass
yeah
they tripping
yeah that [__] supposed to stay in the
house come on let's get it come on yeah
get Beats on yeah but you are [__]
shut the [__] up on one
a little bit baby [__] about to make
big cuz rap
I'm about to make big snap
we on the map
macaroni cheese in the Trap do not get
your [__] ass smack yeah
when I come don't let yeah pull up on
this block with that Mac yeah
we shooting crabs
got a skinny [__] on my lap not for
real
pull up on the fence cause I know they
smoking crack yep come on well I got a
rap yeah yeah
come on why you got arrested I'm a CEO I
don't rap
you lied you said if he wrapped you
would rap
[Music]
try to make it happen get them snaps
yeah now we getting Millions off the rap
yeah I used to take it down the way yeah
I ain't got nothing else to [__] suck
yeah
call me anything just don't call me gay
you know what I'm saying
shout out mace
why did mace what's up with the May
shout out who because I [__] with you
man stop well he was [__] with him he a
gangster turned pretty hey mace's show I
was saying pause
now pause you for that I said that I got
the show it's a great and they always be
saying hey it's a good show that's all
I'm saying damn that's all I'm saying
that's what I'm saying